hello so my name is Lev and I'll talk
about how defying the text similarity
ones using next generation of word
embeddings and Jensen yeah this is my
first talk as not a maintainer of Jensen
we have a new maintainer now called
Yvonne I'm just a contributor right now
so my first slide was supposed to
convince you that Jensen is an awesome
library
I think Robert has just done a very good
job of it in the previous talk where he
used jeomsun dr. vac to analyze comments
so this is kind of redundant but I'll
tell a couple of words Jensen is an open
source package we have board to bag dr.
vac topic modeling it's been around for
about eight years yet check us out on
github we are at this intersection of
academia in industry so we have a lot of
industry adopters a lot of big and small
companies use our code like you know
from Amazon to small startups and at the
same time a lot of people in academia
use our code as well they have about 500
academic citations and generally we take
academic code she's written in C or C++
you know the variables are called gamma
alpha beta there are no comments there
you know it kind of takes you have to
download you know build products from
scratch to compile it you know it's like
this is what code starts with and we
turn it in some Python codes which has
comments she has continuous integration
which is maintainable so they can put in
production be confident about that's the
that's what the mission of Jensen is
take some academic code and make it into
industrial codes and we can get doing it
for about six years
cool so who here has used Jensen before
okay more than a half term awesome and
hopefully the rest of you will try it
out after today stop the credits for
today talk most of things are going to
talk about has been done by parole
parole is our current gen google Summer
of Code student I talk to her every day
so this entire three months this summer
and she had done most of the code here
most of the new features in Jensen are
done by students like this is our
incubator program some business students
use some of you have been to tutorial
and Friday around by Bhargav who is a
graduate of our in committed program so
if you're working on a master see
this or you know you're just a student
or thinking of transition to the designs
like talk to me and you know we'll offer
this free internships we contribute to
open source and learn something about
enoki so yeah just talk to me after this
find me after this talk I'm interested
is okay so let's move to the main you
know topic of this talk in rubber stocks
you've just seen you know how if you
find similar words to you know Briggs it
and you know woman and King and
sometimes words come out similar
synthetic amount not so similar so let's
talk about which words are similar for a
while so this towards coast and shore
are they similar or not so if you think
they're similar the raise your hand I
have like one two three okay most of you
think that similar likewise why do you
think that that similar like somebody
just tell me huh the synonyms okay so
they have the same meaning so like I can
say like I'm walking on the coast and I
say can say I'm walking on the shore we
have the same meaning in the sentence
right depending I just find words oh man
yeah yeah like tokenization is quite
hard like in Chinese we don't even know
what the word boundaries are okay yeah
what is the word yeah what is the
meaning of the word you have to define
what the word is but okay yeah that's
that's even one way deeper let's just
say it's a real sort of understand what
words are let's just talk about the
meaning of words
okay so cause I'm sure they're similar
most of us agree what about clothes and
clothes it's a date is the same or not
okay so if you are similar raise your
hand okay only four or five of you think
that they're similar and rest of you
think probably they're not similar yeah
like I agree that they're similar review
in a sense related like you know the
only same topic the same topic of what
people wear you know like I take my
clothes from the closet they always
appear in the same context you know
they're definitely friends you know that
from the same you know ballpark so they
are definitely related and of course
they're different like you know I put on
my clothes I can say that I put on
my closets that doesn't make any sense
so they're definitely not
interchangeable but they are related so
they're similar words but like what does
similar really mean that is you know so
these are two different notions of
similarity you can find you know invent
your own notions of similarity as much
as you want for your business problem it
might be something special for you okay
and so they're different because they're
not interchangeable and there are some
specific business problems where it
matters which words it's similar in
which words are different and we're
going to talk about this to business
problems today and first one is what
does Elizabeth think about mr. Darcy and
the second one what about the male
characters in Pride and Prejudice like
however you have read Pride and
Prejudice or like so the movie or
something as a familiar context okay
third of the room yeah I've tried to
find some German novel but the drummer
knows are very short it's like you know
like sorors of birds or is 1/3 the
length of Pride and Prejudice and like
you know Franz Kafka trial is like 1/5
so like it's impossible to train models
on them unfortunately so I'm going to
terminology to short so I couldn't find
a good reference I have to use English
English language in brilliant I'm sorry
for that so there's a joke problems but
that has played into real business
problems and the first business problems
you can actually solve with both words
in the topic of Darcy you know what
words in the topic of best customer
service complaints for my company and it
just alleges the general topic of words
you know clothes and closets will be in
the same topic if you were solving
problem number one but if you solving a
different problem if you just want to
find all the named entities in the text
then you actually care about what words
interchangeable with Darcy because all
the males and you know this 19th century
novel they do the same kind of actions
and you'll find that they actually
encode interchangeable words so for
similar words are different in the
context of your business problem so for
first problem which will be attributes
relatedness the second problems will be
interchangeability so the second problem
it will be closed and shor should be
related should be should be similar okay
so let's around some code now
there's a notebook that you can see on
github this is a short URL for that yep
let me see flooding show some code just
to see like first you okay this is
readable cool so so you just you can get
the text of Pride and Prejudice for free
from Project Gutenberg to download it
then you read it and you process it with
spacing I previously talked about the
questions to Robert or about limited
ation and this is just in space it's so
easy you just do it one line less NLP
you know parentheses text and it does
all the pre-processing for you in some
way and you can see there are six
thousand sentences in Pride and
Prejudice and it's about one hundred and
twenty thousand words and they're like
it's kind of small corpus like you need
five hundred thousand towards to make
any where the benek Stuart
but you know you can still get something
you know Verger is forty thousand words
and that doesn't work at all so at least
a hundred twenty thousand words you can
please to get some foothold and see
what's happening like for comparison
English Wikipedia is seventeen million
words and that's really nice models so I
bought a million you gets very nice
models but let's see what we can get one
hundred twenty thousand words so yeah we
just you know in percent support avec
and have a look at our processed
sentences so like this is example of a
process sentence let's fit it on the
screen so this is what it looks like
after limitation and processing so it
suggests the disclaimer of Project
Gutenberg and you see a lot of things
have been removed example yeah some
things have been removed but nature
morals have been removed and this is
what it looks like after preprocessor so
this is one model I'm going to train and
it will be model is predicting the
changeable words like closed on shore
will be similar in this model and this
is just you know one line in Jensen vert
avec take some seconds to run and I want
to see what is the most similar words
here to Darcy and for those you have not
read Pride and Prejudice prior prejudice
has been written it's the first person
it's written from the point of view of
Elizabeth and they are at some point
there is two men who are both interested
in Elizabeth Darcy and Wickham and this
week mr. Wickham comes up with the first
most similar word to Darcy
interchangeable words so that in some
sense interchangeable like they do
similar things and all the other male
characters are in this list you know mr.
Bingley Colon's Gardiner they come out
this way like I'm apologize for using
male characters it just started to use
female characters because of
first-person think like Elizabeth says I
on me and it's like hard to distinguish
between when she says I or somebody in
dialogue says I so female characters
much more complicated in this book so
that's why I had to use male characters
so yep
these are the male characters in the
book and just get them by training this
model yep let's train a different model
and I'll call it attributes of model so
this also takes you know some seconds to
run and the results that I get
attributes to mr. Darcy first guy comes
up with Bingley he's his sidekick and
then at different actions and mr. Darcy
does like you know he's very silent
aloof you know sometimes he smiles you
know and experiences astonishment so
this is just things that shine in the
topic of mr. Darcy and say imagine if
you're analyzing customer complaints if
you look at bad service that you will
see all the words which shine the topic
of bad service if you'll use this
attributes of model but if you use the
interchangeable model you would see just
you know bad service be similar to you
know rude yeah like you know rude waiter
like things that are quite
interchangeable that cool okay let's go
back to the slides those are words cool
yeah
and the parameter that I changed here is
called the window parameter and this
yeah like the difference between these
two models just this window parameter
and window parameter defines when two
words are together so if I save my
window parameter to 2 then I just only
go left to and right two of my words so
if I see Darcy and just go left right
and to right and this is all the friends
of Darcy - I've encountered and the more
frequently I see those words together in
most similar they become and for the
attributes of model I use the window of
50 so basically take my entire sentence
and they all become friends of Darcy and
so I can see more broads differences
here just because I look at the wider
context of the word and that's how I get
to why the topic not just the things
that Darcy does but more like you know
places where he goes and you know
different attributes of him this is just
one parameter called window and this is
a valuation of this models on some pre
annotated data sets so in academia
people think a lot about this two kinds
of similarity the changeable and related
analogies yeah like interchangeable I
just described related to when they're
in the same topic and that's several
data sets that you can use just download
them and see how well your model does on
these two kinds of analysis and you see
that like small window window equals two
that's better than changeable ones and
the window equals 50 that's bad it
related ones and Kindle 15 is sort of
does well in both somewhere in the
middle when you are doing your own
commercial models you actually have to
create these data set from yourself like
if I'm doing customer complaints I have
to create myself this little you know
table where I say that you know bad
customer service and rude should be
similar and you know some other words
should be different but I encourage you
to create your own this little table
things that you want to be similar and
things they want to be different and
that's where you can validate your model
for example yesterday if some of your
own
Miroslav stock he was he was telling you
a couch he was her an example of when
were two VxWorks and when were to deck
doesn't work and like what does mean
words like voice or doesn't work
like it was work someone interchangeable
words but doesn't work for related words
like you have to create your own data
set of things you what if what you
define as works and then you can
evaluate on that and see how well it
drink so that's that's a solution to
that like then no unfortunately good got
a good manually Mart data sets for
customer complaints because they all
come from academia and only talk they
only think about some fundamental you
know linguistic things like in the
changeable words semantically related
words this kind of things but they I
haven't seen any good industry data sets
here but you should create your own for
your own task and then you'll know if
your model is working on it and that way
cool so that was about the window sighs
do you have any questions about it so
far okay we'll have more examples of
questions in the end so then this side
is one hyper parameter and not a
parameter just which algorithm to use
I'll go talk more about the theory of
them in the next ten minutes but this is
just to show you the differences I have
the same window size the fifteen and I
train three different algorithms and
they all give me word embeddings but I
get different results like same data in
different results out and there's a tree
all kinds like for drunk gives you
attributes word Tyvek gives
interchangeable stuff and fostex gives
you a mix of both with the same window
how many of you have heard about fast
text here okay half the room okay what
about war drunk yeah what dark is really
cool in one two three four usually
nobody has scored over rank it seems
like I like the point of this talk like
deliver of ordering to people it's an
awesome algorithm I'll talk more about
this theory later cool so you see like
same stuff in but different algorithms
give you different results let's talk
more about the actually actually let's
run let's run fast text on our Pride and
Prejudice stuff so this is a gem same
API for fast text it looks exactly the
same as the Vorta Veck
you don't need to do anything you fast
text to this library which is released
by Facebook I I research in August it's
written in C++ you know it kind of takes
it's like not so simple to compile
and but it's available in Jensen docker
container because just get Jensen dog
container of all that stuff and you can
use fast text without any compilation
problems and it also has a Python API
now with firm Jensen it's a right now
with just a wrapper but we're by the end
of the summer there's a jisuk student
working on a python python
implementation of it which should be
just native in Python of fostex they
should be easier to use from then on
cool rather than using some C++ library
and so this is just same data coming
into class text and I can I should get
different results okay let's wait for it
to finish in a while
[Music]
yeah it's not so fast it's actually
slower than words avec yeah and like
because I'll tell you why in a second
but it's definitely slower than what's
back there's nothing fast about it yeah
you can see it already even though it's
written in C++ and Monty Python supposed
to be slow and lazy okay cool so there's
our stuff so that the changeable words
is Darcy so I have different versions of
Bennet's and Binkley and gardeners and
we can so this is kind of sort of
similar to that but I have you know
Bennett's and benetiz two different
things and gardeners and gardener Goins
so it's kind of I still get male
characters but it looks different and
for the attributes I get budget after a
longer or one but attributes I think I'm
slightly more meaningful here it's much
better at the it's better at the
attributes in the word track so you can
see yeah this is for Darcy so like yeah
dwell or you know they're just get it
just to me it seems more descriptive of
mr. Darcy's aloof personality how he has
to overcome his pride in this novel
there's another guy in the novel called
Wickham who is not so not such a
positive character and you can see that
his attributes are yeah his attributes
should be more negative than that yep
like you can see drink and should be
concealed in here sometimes yeah okay
that one doesn't yeah okay maybe the
surrounding scene doesn't look so good
yeah on 120,000 words it's very hard to
get something meaningful out of it's
just yeah well some random seeds give
you something good some random things
don't give you something so nice cool
but just see they have different results
for the same inputs different datasets
okay let's go more into the theory of
border bearings so this is probably
going to be the third time the slide
appears in the PI data conference Berlin
2017
you have seen it in Barbara blanks
keynote like this is you know definition
of or the beddings who has seen this
definition before okay okay so I can
just I'll talk about very quickly so if
I have a vocabulary of a thousand words
and I want to find the vector for every
word like what's the easiest way to find
a vector for every board it's just have
one heart's representation like the
world number one will have this vector
which is thousand long everything is a
zero except the first bit the first bit
is turn on one a second word is king so
I will turn on my second which will be
zero one zero zero zero the third word
is book it'll be zero zero one and the
rest of them as ears so this is one way
to represent words I just have a vector
for every words the problem is that
vectors are very long thousand long most
of the stuff is zero the most important
problem with this I don't see a
relationship between king and queen like
king and queen related more later than
their king and book and I don't see that
here at all
you know like king and queen they have
King has one in the first column you
know Queen has in the second book has in
the third there's no relationship
information encoded here and what word
to back and all is worn a been exposed
all guys do they'd create a distributed
representation it's where I have much
less dimensions may be free or 100 not
of thousands much smaller vectors and
the meaning is distributed across all
the dimensions here king is no longer
stuck in the first column with
distribute across the l3 so I have you
know 0.94 and like different floats in
my different dimensions so the meaning
is distributed that's why it's called
distributed representation or you can
call it a void vector or voor de
benicàssim means the same thing and it's
a low dimensional vector space problem
is how do we come up with these numbers
and for them to have some kind of
meaning and that's the theory over Tyvek
so this is example of model train of
Wikipedia and you have the word King and
it's in 100 dimensions and then reflect
it down to 3d using some PCA and I think
in this case so you can see like King
G's in the beginning is in the middle
and then you can see Regicides kind of
things related to King somewhere in the
middle so I mean some people can
all huh good the model is by looking at
this I don't know I cannot really tell
it's happens by this thing is because
it's pca from a haunted dimensions into
something small and the words that check
close together should stay close
together
according to pc intuition words the far
away I couldn't what happens to them on
the PC that's not guaranteed and you
know if you've been to multi liras talks
yesterday on he was talking about how to
evaluate this kind of unsupervised
learning models you know if it's
unsupervised there's no goal how do I
know if it's good or bad so you know
that's what he said yesterday that
projections I mean Inglis you know like
[Laughter]
[Applause]
ok so this is a like this regeneration
is done in terms of words tense
political library you know it's part of
tons of flow visualization package and
yeah you can do this just bring them to
client meetings and like show it's a
client that you use this fancy model to
do it but for actually understanding
models just do this tables that I showed
you like Jen same you know most similar
call and you'll see the numbers you'll
see it in like in a very good way you
know but just they don't really talk
about this projection stuff that much
cool so let's go more into the theory so
how to come up with these vectors like
you know they're floating here in the
space but like I have this you know 0.94
357 just when you do like why does
number select it like what's so good
about them I could just you know
infinitely particulate is fine
so how to come up with this vectors for
King and we will start without you know
corpus corpus is just an empty language
like you know word for data set like if
you NLP torsion you say corpus if you
general to the scientist you know like
vanilla one you say that is it but you
know we'll say corpus don't know why so
this is we have only four sentences now
corpus they about cats because cats are
the thing and one about dogs just you
know for diversity so having a cute
kitten towards cute story cat purred and
now it's and this is like picture of a
cat this is me you know working in my
you know it's my friend's cat I work
remotely sometimes I go to my friends
places also worked remodeling and we
work together for this like co-working
dates it's like a strange idea of having
a board date and
sit in the room and don't talk to each
other and in a work yeah to go to
Martha's house he has a spare desk in
his office for just co-working guests
this is amazing
you know it's like amazing Berlin living
came in a desk in the office for
co-working dates this is you know
amazing city and nowhere else have
scenes okay cool
this is that corpus about cats let's
extract some information out of it so
I'll find out which words are friends
like which words appear in the same
context so kitten has context words of
cute and purred and nod and cat has the
words of you know cute furry in mouth
and dog is you know loud very random bit
so okay let's make it into metrics so
kitten and cute appear twice together
and keep in a very pure zero times
together and in a kitchens bit appear
zero times together two so that's a
co-occurrence matrix that's already
really good metrics if I look at the row
for kitten and row for cats they're
pretty similar like you know they have
the same they have both numbers in the
first dimension so that's awesome
yep and I can already see the keeping
the cat is similar and dog is different
from them but the probably problem is
Mattox is it's you know a 10,000 by
10,000 which might have a 7,000 words in
my vocabulary and have 10,000 you know
contacts words that's only problem is
it's really big it's really informative
but it's just too big for to do anything
meaningful with it yeah that's the only
problem with it so let's do the
emotionality reduction let's make it
smaller just let's factorize it into two
small messages so I have vocab Bible cab
and it becomes what cup times something
small times something small by the cup
and the first row in the U matrix is
just something that describes kitten
some you know hidden meaning of kitten
will be in that matrix and that will be
you know maybe a hundred long not ten
thousand but just like a hundred long
that's how I get my board embeddings
that's basically what all of them really
do yeah like there's some caveats here
is you want to read like if you read
materia it's not exactly like that but
that's enough intuition for the first
approximation for the benning's that's
that's how it happens okay the okay the
three by four different from free by for
my laptop
sorry about the they're different the
problem of the slides if I have a vector
for a word and have a vector for a
context and I do that dot product what I
should get is the co-occurrence count
like I have a kitten and you know cute
appear twice so the dot product of these
two vectors should be higher than the
dot product of you know cats and cubes
because cat can cure my dear ones they
should have small dot products and
kitten cute this two vectors should have
a high dot product so that's all I'm
trying to do is just approximating this
dot product with I haven't want
microcurrents count to be equal to the
dot product of these two vectors and
that's how virtue deck works and that's
the same as the similarity you know the
same with fingers with similarity of two
vectors I want to I want to hear my
kitten acute will be more similar than
cat and cute because they appear more
times together they will be more similar
in the same context so similarity is
basically the same as co-occurrence in
this virtual world you can think about
that way in the fast X world things are
different the similarity there is not
just the co-occurrence of words together
it actually goes deeper and goes into
sub words so if I look at the word going
it's split into many different parts it
becomes the Gio Oy
in I look at all that all the two
corrected chunks of that and the free
character chunks of it as well and then
I want to see the similarity of you know
going in cat I look at all those chunks
of cats Eliot chunks of going and how
often they they to appear together and
Sam - I'm up over all of them so like I
will have you know see cat and go Kay
and ink you know a tea and ink and I'll
go deeper into sub words I mean and it's
kind of nice because I can see that
going can go will be similar because
they'll have the same in a word Gio and
Gio and it definitely has some meaning
in it so let's around some code it shows
that so for example the word night
appears in Pride and Prejudice but the
word night doesn't appear there because
I did limitation so Spacey
took nights and changed
night for me just to make my life easier
so the model this model has never seen
the word nights but actually things that
they're very similar even though it's
never seen the word nights you can still
see that the they have shared a lot of
sub words together and therefore there
should be similar the funny thing here
is that also thing that night night is
something that's never seen before like
their you know their guy who rides a
horse and armor and so for the fortnight
it also things that night and nights are
very similar like you know 99.9% similar
because the only different one word in
one in one character and just looks at
the sub words and finds a lot of
stimulus of words in them and it didn't
want to unfortunately never had a chance
to learn meaning of nights the only way
it could have learnt it is by seeing
it's used in a lot of examples and Jana
you know and the Jane Austen never used
the word night in her novel
unfortunately so the more like never had
a chance to use it and it can confuse
the things that the word night is
lighted tonight and that's that's a
problem if you look at the sub words and
this thing of looking at you know chunks
of words that's really like a poor man's
morphology like normally I would get
trained linguists who will tell me this
is the roots you know this is ending
this is this bitless at that bit or and
create some kind of rules to me to split
the words into chunks and if I cannot do
that let's just do it in a hacky way
just try all the different combinations
try all different sub junks see what's
more important and you know maybe that
will help me in some way it actually
works really well yep so it works really
well but it's also slower and it
originally slower is because I have much
more vectors in my vocabulary so if
having one word going have word goal
have the word Inc and have the O in in
there so this my vocabulary is much
bigger and I have to consider much more
candidates that's why I fast X is slower
than anything else I should call it slow
text maybe I don't know but it behaves
much better for interchangeable words
because like the changeable words
usually have some parts of the words
shared between them are going and go
that quite an exchangeable
so that's a looking at it should stop
words really
interchangeable problem really well so
you can see from changing awards
accuracy plastics blows everything out
of the water you can feel like this big
you know orange spike here cool
yeah you already seen IPI it's precise
Texas the same as for anything else in
order that and fast X actually slower
than the Python works back even if you
don't look at the word chunks if you say
it only look at the word chunks of
maximum length zero so just don't look
at navour chunks at all and then it
should do the same thing as Python words
avec and the C++ code should really beat
Python but it doesn't so you know it's a
PI data so I just wanted to show you the
Python it's quite fast and performant I
mean of course it uses syphon underneath
it just the C but you know it's still
Python okay cool and then many ways to
get vector forward I've showed you word
to the XPath section were drunk you can
just like take this co-occurrence matrix
of kitten is very and factorize it in
simple SVD you know you can try glove I
convolve are embed that many different
ways to find the word embeddings just
try different things see what works for
you in many ways
okay cool let's move to for drank so
word rank is this word embedding which
is a couple of years old and this is
quite nice it's such a different
formulation of a problem in Vorta Veck
is a classification problem where I have
an input context cute and I want to see
what's the best friend of cute and it
comes up with kitten so just have to
predict you know one word out in word
Ryan kids the different problem so I
have my context convenience is cute
and I want to see what are the drank me
all the friends of cute
you know rank all the words and how
friendly they are towards cute and the
first one is going to be saying with
kitten but the second one is going to be
cat and my third one's gonna be dog
because you know dog and cute never
appear together because dogs are not
cute and they're you know and kitten and
catches was cute once and kitten those
cute twice so that's why you know
they're ranked this way but you have to
create the whole ranking and there's
even a cost metrics here the cost metric
here so mistake at the top cost you much
more than mistake at the bottom and when
I look at more similar like how do you
use for the Ben equal zero you only
normally
you know like where's like this way like
I just do gem same or similar and what I
care about is the ranking that's really
how they used and what rank directly
predicts that thing for me that's the
goal of word rank is to give me the top
ten very well and does not care about
the rest of them for Tyvek just cares
about the top one and word rank actually
does what I usually use the word
debating sperm cool so this is if this
is the difference between foreground
convert to rank and it does it hasn't we
have a wrap around were drunk you know
the IP I is the same as four to back you
can easily switch your models in
production just to see which which works
better for you that is the library in
C++ which has you know many dependencies
but just get the docker container and to
work you know yes you don't have to
install some you know some numeric
libraries cool the only problem is were
drunk it takes forever to run because
it's a much harder problem you're not
just predicting one point to predicting
you know all the whole ranking and then
something that takes 18 seconds to run
like Vortech takes 18 seconds to run a
million words fast X is 50 seconds you
know you're bored waiting for fast text
ten minutes ago in for drank I'm not
gonna train watering today it's you know
it takes really long time to train
that's the only problem with it takes
four hours the Train but it works really
well if you have a little data and you
want to find this related accuracy
between related relationship between
clothes and closets that's works really
well for that like this is some test
results even on a small data so this is
the table on what you should use and
when so if you want to similar words to
be related like while it is like clothes
and closet if you want describes just
the topic and you want to know what the
document is about then you should run
for drunk and even like a small corpus
like 1 billion words is a very small
corpus and what rank on a million words
worked just as well as words of a con 5
million words and for this specific
related task so it's really good for
that it's quite noise resistance because
of the ranking and yeah like has anyone
used learning to rank before for
anything like this the whole world of
machine learning where just do learning
to rank okay it's one person heard about
learning to rank I haven't heard about
it until encountered for drugs it was
like discovery that this whole thing
existed it's actually much more noise
resistant than predicting a point
producing the whole ranking is more fun
sometimes cool and another problem is if
you want to recognize names in your text
and you just care about the function of
the words and watch things that can be
to change live then you should use word
to back of a small window or fostex to
the small window and a small window like
equals two and that's if you want to get
different similarity like
interchangeable words and this is the
same thing but in a flow diagram you
know just as a not a table but it's a
flow diagram so my single words are
related go left you know my similar word
is interchangeable then I should go to
fast text verge of ech
varam bad you know if you got a million
words use words back if you have got
less than a million words used for drank
yeah this is the gist of the talk
basically of this next generation of
foreign embeddings which are there does
beyond words back something else you can
try and usually should try cool yeah
thanks for listening still for me yeah
find me on Twitter
[Applause]
nice talk I'm curious about double
meaning words so let's say can as a
container and can as a verb or how it
affects these word embeddings and do we
have a way to identify them through
their embedding yep so that definitely
ways to do it that different algorithms
which you can try the simplest thing
that you can try is if you use Spacey
for pre-processing can also tell you
which part of speech it is if it's a
noun or a verb and that's where you just
have you know can slash and then of can
slash VB the you just put them into your
model as like two different strings just
have a string called can slash on em and
can slash VB and you get two different
embeddings for them so that's the
easiest way to do it and using space C
program it takes slightly longer to
pre-process it because you have to do
this parsing but space is pretty fast
that's the easiest way to solve it there
are a lot of academic papers about it
but in commercial consulting somehow it
hasn't really come up as a problem like
if you look at you know plus insurance
text usually the words have like words
the words have only one meaning there
because it's kind of specific domain and
there we never really had to use it this
kind of tricks but it is a good question
to ask thank you
I thank you for the talk one question in
your experience compared to fast text
and word drink and verge of AK how does
glove to do it
gloved us pretty well the only problem
with it that how its implemented the is
Apple and Python there's no performant
implementation of glove in Python and
the reason for that is you have to start
the whole co-occurrence matrix at once
like you have to take your corpus and
process it and you have to you know have
you know 10,000 by 10,000 metrics and
you have to create it and store it in
memory and that if a cobbler is large it
takes you know a little while and you
have to go through a whole corpus before
you can even start doing love words avec
does it in a streaming manner so you
don't have to have this whole thing
don't have to see the whole corpus at
once you can just stream things through
and simplicity construct this of
Corcoran's metrics just by streaming it
through that's the just engineering
aspect of glove makes it hard to use in
production that's that's the problem
with it but yeah glove is working quite
well yeah there's not much difference
between glove and words avec it just has
a better formula so it's much more
explicit it's nicer paper to read you
know and academic conferences people
talk about gloves and talk about for
debating in in the industrial complex to
talk about for Tyvek when you say for
the MINIX
you know just matter of environment if
I'm working on a huge corpus and if I'm
fiddling with the parameter such as
number of dimensions for the vector and
the context window size of course it
takes a lot of time to train for the
huge corpus so should I try it and try
it or is there kind of an optimistic
kind of values or is there a relation
between these the length of the sentence
and the dimensionality of the vector to
be used okay so they are to have a
parameters that you can do like the
dimension of the model and the window
size so the window size is more about
the meaning that you capture see once
you do a more similar you can you can
already see
what amount of things is more similar if
you get names then your window size is
in a small if you know if you get too
vague things then even the sizes too big
you just get it from looking at similar
words the dimension size is different
the measure size as usual you know
overfitting under fitting just general
machine learning model thing like the
bigger mo dimensions you are the easier
it is for you to oh the fit on the
training set you know and have bad
performance on the test so if you have
you know accuracy on your training is 99
and on your test site it's you know 50
then it means your dimension is too big
so that's how you tune the dimension
parameter so I need to try to personally
with the with the test cases and then I
need to change it again
yeah but heuristics are different for
window size in one heuristic just
looking at most similar list of more
similar words and four dimensional size
I have different heuristic but looking
at training and test at performance okay
yeah
[Applause]